Over the years, Jar Jar Binks has become emblematic
of the Star Wars prequel era — as well as
the totem the internet holds up to argue how
terrible those three films were.
In the years following the release of The
Phantom Menace, fans denounced Jar Jar as
little more than a cheap money grab made to
sell toys… and that was at best.
At worst, they described him as all the worst
aspects of Star Wars distilled into one character
— with some critics suggesting the character
represented a racist stereotype, on account
of his cartoonish accent.
"No, no mesa stay. Mesa called Jar Jar Binks.  Mesa your servant."
At the center of all this, though, was the
man who portrayed Jar Jar: Ahmed Best.
When he was cast for the first Star Wars movie
in in almost 20 years, Best was coming off
a celebrated turn in the hit musical Stomp
in San Francisco.
And in 1997, Best went into production on
The Phantom Menace with bright eyes and a
cheerful attitude.
It's easy to see how much fun he had behind
the scenes of The Phantom Menace, too: singing,
dancing, and chipper as ever, even when he
was draped in latex during a searing Tunisian
summer.
But that all changed in May 1999.
Practically everybody who was around back
then was aware of the fan backlash against
the inclusion of Jar Jar Binks in Star Wars
canon.
And in fairness, Best's overwrought Buster
Keaton impression didn't exactly fit well
into a film all about taxes and trade confrontations.
Even so, however, it's easy to forget today
just how toxic that backlash became.
A number of hate websites cropped up on the
internet, wishing all kinds of horrible things
upon the character.
Even major news entertainment outlets ran
stories about the frothing hate against Jar
Jar that, over time, gradually became more
and more disturbing.
Some Star Wars fans even led calls for Gungan
genocide; comments which were probably intended
to be humorous — but which nonetheless feel
particularly un-funny in this day and age.
It's not that Jar Jar Binks was just unliked
or even hated — it's that so many people
relished the idea of exterminating something
that only existed as a fictional construct.
To his credit, George Lucas warned Best ahead
of time that there might be anger in response
to Jar Jar the same way there had been to
the Ewoks [EE-woks] in Return of the Jedi.
And for what it's worth, Lucas also publicly
defended Best when the backlash turned out
to be much, much worse than either of them
could have imagined.
Sadly, however, people can only hold up against
so much public vilification for so long.
After taking about as much as anyone can be
expected to take, Best became suicidal.
In July 2018, the actor revealed in a Twitter
post that he nearly decided to jump off a
bridge due to the media backlash against Jar
Jar — a backlash that still affects his
career today.
Several months later, he opened up in greater
detail about how the harassment he faced for
playing Jar Jar Binks pushed him to consider
suicide.
"I just wanted to play a part. It was exhausting, you know."
Over the last 20 years, Star Wars fans have
had plenty of time to reflect on the successes
and failures of the prequel movies.
And for many of the people who were around
when The Phantom Menace was released, it's
given them a chance to realize that Jar Jar
isn't exactly a treasonous crime against Star
Wars.
With that reassessment came empathy — and
in the online responses to Best's confession,
many apologized for getting wrapped up in
the frenzied fever of Jar Jar hate.
Fortunately, Best's bad experience with the
Star Wars universe hasn't put him off making
a long-overdue return.
In 2020, Lucasfilm will debut Star Wars: Jedi
Temple Challenge, a kids' game show featuring
a range of physical challenges and contests
— and all of it will be hosted by Best himself.
Still, though, it's lucky things turned out
so well.
Sometimes it's easy to forget that the Star
Wars movies are made by people with real lives
and feelings, performing their craft earnestly
in good faith.
Best's story is proof that everyone would
be far better off if fans took that to heart.
If you or anyone you know is having suicidal
thoughts, please call the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline at 1-800-273-TALK (8255).